やってきましたね
この季節が
たま～にこういうのやるんすよね
今回もちょっと気になるインターネットの情報がありまして
実際にそれをやってみようかと思います
というものがございます
必要なモノは
鏡４枚
ろうそくを１本
準備してくださいと
はあああ、さむ！今、寒気来んかった？
ほら！鳥肌！
合わせ鏡の中に
何か試した人がいるらしいんすよ
試した人がいるみたいなんですけども！
ショックで口がきけなくなってしまい
いまだに鏡に何が映ったか分からないらしいです
止めましょう！
何で！
信じろよ！
バカ野郎！やるしかねぇ～だろう！
怖え～！
今何時？ちなみに
後、１５分後に儀式が出来る時間なりますので
さっそく、準備をして行きましょう！
では行こう！
こっちが北だよね？
南
東
西
オッケ、オッケ
鏡は四つ買って来ました
うおぉー！
お？何か映っててね？もう
嘘？
人の顔が映ってね？これ
え？何これ？
あ、俺の腕だった！
ビックリした！
ホントに止めて！
ビックリした！マジで！
ねえ！鏡怖い！怖い怖い怖い
わっわ鳥肌ほらもう...ヤバイ完全にヤバかった
合わせ鏡が良くないんだよね？
心霊的に
はい、という訳で鏡四つ準備できました
ハッピー ジャムジャム さいこう
そんな、そんな感じじゃなくない？今？
よっ！
いっつ
ぅわっ！暗！
うわ！ビックリした！
♪ステップ踏～めばパパパッパッパラッパ～ラダイスー　ってってってって～れ
て～てってて
てっ
てっ！
はい！出来ました！大体こんな感じだと思います
後はこの真ん中にろうそくを置きます
ただ今の時刻は、ただ今12時40分！
あと、7分後に始まります
行ってきま～ あっでもこんなふざけたテンションじゃ怒られちゃう
実際に何かが見えるかも知れないのでやって行きましょう！
ちょい、四角にはまいた、この部屋
うん
はい、あと１０秒後です
行きましょう
ヤバイ、ヤバイ、ヤバイ
46分になった
え、なった？
うん
という訳で実験スタート
もうやだ、ホントに
うわ～
今、頭痛した！
何か、怖くて見れなくね？
見れないね
う～わ！さむっ！
見れない！
見れない見れない見れない見れない
ねえホントに止めて！
炭酸水ぐらい飲ませてよ！
何か聞いたんだけどさ
合わせ鏡、うわっ！
何でこんなに？
あ、ヤバイ見ちゃった
せーので見よ！
せーのっ
う～わ
見てみ、奥
すっげー奥まで自分が出てくる
伝わるかな、この
めっちゃ奥まで繋がってる感じです
えーと、儀式開始から3分経過しました
未だに大きな変化見られないので
ちょっと、まだ何とも言えないんですけども
引き続き見て行こうと思います
めっちゃ耳がキィーンってするんだよ
何も見えないよ
わっ！！
わわわわわわっわあっわ
わ！！あ！